iniciativas femininas transformam
estruturalmente o nosso sistema
econômico e social investir uma maior
quantidade de mulheres e meninas ativas
e economicamente e também independentes
financeiramente não é só investir no
crescimento do programa econômico
mundial mas também expandir mercados e
garantir uma maior saúde e educação para
todos
estamos falando de impacto social
o avanço da igualdade de gênero pode
adicionar 12 trilhões ao crescimento
mundial empresas lideradas por mulheres
e apoiadas por venter capitão no carro
no vale do silício tiver um crescimento
de 12% a mais do que as empresas
lideradas por homens mas o nosso sistema
capitalista ele se desenvolveu em torno
de uma cultura patriarcal que carrega
muitos valores masculinos valores dos
quais não com tempo nós mulheres e muito
menos a nossa natureza
valores estes como o crescimento linear
o individualismo a competição e
hierarquia dominação de pessoas e
recursos ea lógica da escassez
isso trouxe alguns resultados pra gente
mulheres hoje ganham em média 26% a
menos do que os homens em todos os
setores
se a gente fizer um recorte um pouco
mais aprofundado é o salário das
mulheres negras representavam 43 por
cento do salário dos homens brancos
quanto maior o nível hierárquico dentro
da escola dentro das corporações dentro
das empresas é menor a quantidade de
mulheres nas lideranças e maior
disparidade salarial entre eles ea hoje
as mulheres elas realizam quase três
vezes a mais dos trabalhos domésticos
em homens e sem contar com um problema
no mercado de trabalho é muito latente
um problema que é o fato de nós sermos
geradora de vida de novas vidas e de
todo mês a gente se preparar para
receber a fertilidade e de todo mês a
gente tem um ciclo como da natureza e
como da lua esse mercado e esse sistema
ele não contempla essa natureza
a gente não consegue se recolher em
introspecção em troca de sabedoria com
outras mulheres como faziam as nossas
nações e como os farei como fazem ainda
em algumas tribos indígenas
muito pelo contrário
48% das mulheres são demitidas após um
ano do nascimento dos seus filhos
se você for perguntar três em cada dez
mulheres têm medo de serem demitidos ao
engravidar mas eu estou trazendo pra
vocês verem como que esses valores
masculinos enraizado no nosso sistema
econômico social eles aumentam ajudam a
perpetuar as questões de paridade de
gênero mas durante muito tempo eu mesma
reproduzir-se de valores masculinos e
isso me agrediu profundamente é o meu
apelido sempre foi trator de pelúcia e
se pode até parecer engraçado hoje mas
durante muito tempo isso me ofender um
pouco
é eu tinha objetivos muito claros e eu
era completamente conectada com o plano
material somente conquistei algumas
coisas ainda muito nova e pra mim o
sucesso era muito óbvio dinheiro e
reconhecimento me importava mais muito
outras coisas sabe é completamente
desconectada eu ofendi eu magoei eu
agredir e perdi muitas pessoas de
convivência ao longo do ano
bush desatenta
eu mesma me tornei aquilo que de uma
certa forma hoje eu não acredito mais
e aí num determinado momento eu fui
violentada sexualmente e eu tratei disso
como se fosse uma episódio qualquer da
minha vida como se fosse um dia qualquer
sem a plena noção dos traumas que isso
podia trazer a minha vida
junto a isso as responsabilidades elas
foram aumentando e foram crescendo e eu
fui me esconder atrás de uma personagem
que eu achava que era minha
personalidade
a marcela trator de pelúcia mulher de
negócios aquela saber mas mais do que
muito homem
pois é ela se vestir a maior parte do
tempo de preto cortes retos largos que
era pra esconder aquele corpo violado e
odiado por muitos acúmulos emocionais e
eu não percebi que aqui virão pra um
padrão nocivo para a minha vida
muito pelo contrário eu continuo em
frente seguir o meu objetivo porque o
planejamento era muito correto tava
dando supercerto
aquilo parecia um sucesso e eu entendi
eu achava que eu tinha conquistado as
coisas que eu conquistei porque eu era
exatamente daquele jeito mas aí
em 2015 a coisa começou a mudar um pouco
e o meu caminho retornou de volta
atenção plena uma pessoa da minha
família estava quase morrendo e as
ferramentas que eu tinha era tão eram
tão duras que eu não podia usá los
naquele momento a história era muito
mais objetivo do que aquilo e eu não
sabia o que fazer
eu me senti completamente impotente
naquele momento
an mas tudo passou tudo passou eu adoeci
bastante mas ninguém percebeu
mas eu fiquei depressiva eu tive crises
de pânico estar aqui no palco era uma
tremenda vulnerabilidade para mim o
rendimento naquele momento e tudo passou
o meu irmão ele ficou bem eu consegui me
reconectar e vivenciar muitos processos
de auto conhecimento que me voltaram
para dentro de mim que fizeram eu cuidar
de mim mesmo e naquele momento tive que
parar para dar atenção àquela situação
da minha família
e naquele momento em que eu parar eu
pensei puxa eu não parei antes não
parecia meu dia a dia o professor
e aí recém completas de 30 recém
completados os meus 30 anos de
existência eu pude me reconectar com que
eu tenho de mais profundo com os meus
valores com a minha essência e pude
trazer a serviço do que eu tenho de
ferramentas profissionais com a missão
que eu tenho nessa existência e é esse
meu trabalho que eu faço hoje na terra a
rede de incentivos femininas muitas
iniciativas surgiram com o intuito de
resolver algumas questões do universo
feminino e é um pouco desse foco que a
gente atua reduzir as desigualdades
entre as oportunidades as oportunidades
sociais e econômicas entre os homens e
mulheres principalmente na liberdade
financeira
a mulher quando tem a liberdade
financeira ela consegue conquistar
também uma liberdade de tomada de
decisão e não só uma liberdade tomada de
decisão para empreender mas também uma
tomada de decisão para sair de uma
situação de vulnerabilidade de violência
e é nisso que a gente atua hoje
impulsionar o empreendedorismo de
mulheres a se conectar com que elas têm
de maior realidade maior força para que
elas sejam protagonistas das suas
próprias histórias
mas eu quero trazer para vocês aqui uma
ideia sobre novos valores que a gente
precisa trazer para o nosso sistema
econômico para os novos negócios novos
negócios são os valores femininos como
cuidadosamente traz o conceito de
economia do feminino com a jennifer
brasil
esses valores femininos eles precisam
começar a faltar os nossos negócios e à
nossa economia
são valores estes como crescimento
circular a colaboração sustentabilidade
suficiência cuidado empatia abundância e
principalmente conexão nota da natureza
para que a gente possa de fato ter uma
mudança sistêmica que nos coloque de
volta a uma noção de inclusão e
redistribuição de dinheiro poder
ela propõe 12 princípios da economia do
feminino dos quais eu me alinho bastante
eu vou compartilhar três deles com vocês
o primeiro deles é integrar reúna todas
suas partes recupere as partes do seu
corpo que ficaram espalhadas por aí
perdoe a si mesmo volte para sua casa
volte para o seu corpo integre-se
segundo incorpora os seus valores e
prosperar economicamente em quando fico
enquanto vivemos a partir dos nossos
valores é profundamente perturbador para
a atual ordem social e económica que
vivemos o time à sua autoridade interna
e terceiro um negócio pode ser um novo
modelo para uma ordem social econômica e
nós como empreendedores e empreendedores
nós temos a oportunidade de agitar essa
atual ordem social econômica e política
experimentando novos modelos de negócio
que tragam a valorização da humanidade e
da terra
thomas como que eu posso fazer isso hoje
é a minha sugestão é que a gente comece
parando respirando um pouco e se
conectando com o princípio de tudo é
mais simples do que a gente possa
imaginar
o maior poder que nós mulheres temos é o
de reconexão com a terra com a natureza
a gente vive esse ciclo todos os meses
a gente não pode se transformar em
tratores que passam por cima dessa
natureza
a natureza é feminina por si só ela é
regenerativa ela respeita os ciclos e o
tempo natural das coisas
portanto empreenda a partir do que está
viva em você do que de pulsa abre espaço
para as possibilidades e das
oportunidades que possam acontecer
valorize os seus skills monetize seus
valores e seus skills e traga para o seu
dia-a-dia algumas características
femininas como em prospecção
a empatia ea gentileza e por último a
joão politicamente é importante que a
estrutura sistêmicas suporte a
transformação de consciência que a gente
está vivendo
e as estruturas sistêmica só vai vir com
mudanças de leis que comporta em novos
valores econômicos hajam a revolução já
começou e vamos agir juntos e juntas
juntas para que a gente consiga
transmutar história que nos foi contada
e que a gente possa escrever o nosso
futuro
a ro
[Aplausos]